a growing number of airlines are banning
luggage with built-in tracking devices
or phone chargers there are concerns
that lithium-ion batteries and so-called
smart bags could cause a fire United and
Hawaiian Airlines said yesterday they'll
start banning smart bags with non
removable batteries January 15th at
least four other airlines announced
similar restrictions this month Kris Van
Cleave is at Reagan National Airport
outside Washington with the apparent
dangers Kris good morning good morning
well this is a smart bag you can see my
phone is plugged into it and charging as
we speak here the maker of this bag says
they've got about 65,000 or so out there
that could be affected by this and the
issue is right here this is the battery
since you can't take it out this bag is
going to be on a no-fly list the
internal battery that can be a Flyers
dream could become a travel nightmare in
January as airlines banned pricey smart
bags with lithium-ion batteries that
cannot be removed the carrier's worried
checked bags could catch fire if those
batteries malfunction we know there are
some smart bags out there that will no
longer be permitted to fly on American
Airlines Ross Feinstein is from American
Airlines the world's largest carrier
which was the first to ban the bags if
the bank has to be checked you must
remove that battery and bring it into
the cabin of the aircraft with you but
if the bag has to be checked and you the
battery is not removable we're not gonna
be able to accept that bag earlier this
year the FAA urged international
regulators to prohibit large electronics
with lithium-ion batteries from checked
bags new testing revealed the potential
for a catastrophic fire so intense the
planes extinguishers wouldn't put it out
smart bags use their batteries to power
onboard GPS sync with an app way and
lock themselves plus charge your phone
some can even propel themselves putting
them on many holiday wish lists bags
with the batteries removed will be
allowed on board but then expensive
features like the ability to track it
won't work the manufacturers have to
adapt or they manufactured essentially
useless bags sort of like bringing your
bottle of water through the security
checkpoint you're going to get there and
they're going to tell you your
I can't fly now what do you do blue
smart the maker of this bag and a
leading maker of smart bags tells CBS
this morning in a statement we did our
due diligence to make sure that we
complied with all international
regulations defined by the Department of
Transportation and the FAA it is a step
back not only for travel technology but
it also presents an obstacle to
improving the way we all travel it is
worth noting that do TN FAA do not
certify specific batteries or products
as FAA approved to be checked in terms
of lithium-ion batteries north all right
Chris thanks I have for those bags I was
going to say I just got one as a gift
and was very excited until I saw
Christmas before thank you Chris
you can use it around the house from the
kitchen to the family now I know what to
get you I'll get you a small fire
expedient have one of those